do you think is the biggest Untold
narrative the thing that the the media
have been missing for for years and
years or suppressing for years and years
the most nefarious type of fake news is
when they do not cover something they
ignore a story so for months and months
and months when mainstream media is not
covering the Border that's a type of
fake news because they are controlling
what the narrative is deception by
choice right that's a that's a really
really interesting concept they're
deciding what people can pay attention
to and you know if for those of you that
are uh let's say Gen X or above uh you
remember when at 6:30 on ABC NBC and CBS
they had their news programs and and
really they covered the about the exact
same stuff almost in the exact same
order it might have been a little bit
different but if you were watching NBC
News at 6:30 with Tom Brokaw and then
you flipped over to CBS News or to ABC
news with Peter Jennings it was
basically the same stuff maybe they
changed which way they were showing it
like okay that's Story number one this
is Story number four but it was
basically the same so the Overton window
stayed the same was sort of like this
and then everybody in the country kind
of believe the same stuff cable news
comes in eventually of course the
internet comes in and now news is
bubbling up from the bottom there are
there are uh Twitter
reporters Robert F Kennedy Jr going to
the Border going uh there's a problem
here Elon Musk going into the Border oh
there's a problem here and the
mainstream media is pissed about that so
this idea of the over tin window what we
are allowed to talk about uh that really
is the issue here Elon had a bit more to
say about that what do you think is the
biggest Untold narrative the thing that
the the media have been missing for for
years and years or suppressing for years
and
years um well there's a few things but
um you know I I I I've generally try to
say like to increase what the so-call
overturn window of what can be discussed
what what you know what what is it okay
to discuss without being ostracized
um suddenly attacking Dei was you know
would have been ostracized before not
and not anymore
um and
um you know any anything that's sort
of
sensitive or or that the media ignores
uh the public can then you know raise
the raise it on on the xplatform and and
and make that an actual topic of
discussion what's interesting about sort
of Citizen Journal ISM or it's not even
it's not even journalism what's
interesting about a guy who wanders down
to a Border Town and just like sees
what's going on and then shares his
thoughts is that it bubbles up from the
bottom and then the people decide oh
that is in boy that's interesting why
wasn't that on CNN so this leads us to
the question so what is being discussed
on X Twitter and say on Rumble and
locals and places like that that is
basically being completely ignored by
mainstream Media or mainstream media is
just getting to it really late right
mainstream media is kind of covering the
Border stuff now because they cannot
ignore it anymore it makes them look
completely complicit and or
ridiculous